So Dr. Zakya, what is the significance
of taking the sahur the pre-dawn meal?
>> According to the saying of a beloved
prophet wasallam, it's mentioned in say
Bkari volume number three in the book of
fasting hadith number 1923 where a
beloved prophet said that sahur the
pre-dawn meal in it is blessing. It's
mentioned in Sahim Muslim volume number
two in the book of fasting hadith number
that it's mentioned that the difference
between the fasting of the Muslims and
the people of the book the Alikab the
Jews and Christian is the taking of the
sahur the pre-dawn meal. So that is act
which differentiates between the fasting
of the Muslims and the people of the
book the Jew and the Christians. It's
mentioned in the Asaya volume number
three hadith number 1045. Our beloved
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam said
that blessings are found in three
things.
One is the jama that is a congregation.
The two is aid that's a sort of a food
and the third is the sahur the pre-dawn
meal. A similar message is repeated in
Sahaya volume number three had number
1291 where our beloved prophet said
blessings are in two things one is sahur
and one is a just measurement that is
while weighing
and there are several hadith in which a
beloved prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam he has talking about sahur that
in it is blessing and it's better for
the Muslim um it's also mentioned in say
al jame volume number one had number
3683 Three, one of the Sabbath enters
the house of the prophet when he's
having a sur and the prophet says that
in the s is a blessing so do not leave
it. And a similar message is given in
Musnad Ahmed where the prophet said that
sahur is blessed. So do not leave it
even if you have a gulp of water because
Allah and his angels they send blessings
on the person who has sahur. And similar
message has given several say hadith
including sun Abu Dawud volume number
two hadith number 2337
where a person enters when the prophet
is having his sur and the prophet says
that have sur it is a blessing for you
and in the sur is a blessing. So there
are various hadith talking about the
blessings of sahur. So it is a nyama and
the reason the prophet always said that
have so that the people don't overburden
themselves because when we fast they
should have the sahur so that you know
they don't overburden themselves and
they have the proper fast.